richtig ist senkt wenn du das muss hallo
mein name ist luca und ich habe vor
einigen tagen bereits ein video
hochgeladen in dem ich einen grundschule
test absolviert habe ich glaube ich
entscheide mich doch für das in dem
betrieb auf der rechten seite ja ich bin
jetzt nicht so die hellste kerze auf
worte allerdings habe ich einen neuen
test gefunden um ein glorreiches
unendliches wissen unter beweis zu
stellen und zwar heißt dieses video
schaffst du den hauptschulabschluss
ich hoffe mal wir haben uns gefragt ob
ihr das auch schaffen und haben hier für
euch jeweils vier fragen aus den
bereichen deutsch mathe und
gesellschaftskunde das waren die drei
fächer bei denen ich komplett
eingeschlossen habe bei dem grundschul
test hatte ich nur bei englisch alles
richtig deswegen wie ich bin gespannt
hoch richtige antwort gibt es einen
punkt ihr müsst mindestens drei der vier
fragen richtig beantworten um einen der
bereiche zu bestehen die aufgaben sind
identisch mit denen aus der bayer
es ist nicht
schluss sondern der qualifizierende
hauptschulabschluss das heißt es ist
noch mal ein bisschen schwieriger an die
diesen test besteht dann hättet ihr
höchstwahrscheinlich auch die
hauptschule prüfung bestanden
legen wir los mit dem ok aufgabe 1 es
geht um das wort qualifikation wie viele
silben hat das wort
das ist ja
si
eine silbe qualifikation 5
o
sex ich glaube zionist eine silbe also
qualifikation fünf sage ich richtig ist
sechs wenn du das muss
mein kopf
lass mich da wird in ruhe das ist ja
unfassbar no steht ihr könnt ja wieder
mal in den kommentaren mit raten aber
das macht halt wirklich nur sinn wenn
ihr selber auch während des videos mit
ratet also schreibt am besten jetzt
schon langen kommentar fangen an erste
aufgabe als fünf oder sechs gesagt habt
vielleicht haben auch einige 15 gesagt
und jetzt kommen auf jeden fall zur
zweiten aufgabe und da könnte ja auch
wieder während dieser überlegt zeit eure
antworten reinschreiben ich muss das
jetzt richtig haben nenne das
entsprechende werk von qualifikation in
der grundform qualifizieren oder etwas
ganz anderes gemeint also ich würde
sagen das wort qualifizieren macht auf
jeden fall sind deswegen mal warten
wichtig ist qualifizieren
doch nicht so blöd wie ich aussehe als
nächstes was ist der plural von
qualifikationen a
die mehrzahl
qualifikationen oder qualifikations nee
ich denke schon dass qualifikationen die
mehrzahl richtig qualifikationen
ok also deutsch haben wir abgeschlossen
und ich habe zwei von drei bisher
richtig
wir hatten vier fragen in jedem fach
nicht mehr das weiß ich aus welcher
sprache stammt das wort qualifikation
ursprünglich
latein ich kann mir schon vorstellen
irgendwie als grundform mehr oder
weniger qualifiziertes oder irgendwie so
aber also fast alle wörter stammen aus
dem dateien qualifikation stammt aus dem
lateinischen drei von vier habe ich
richtig das war es mit deutsch wenn du
drei oder vier punkte hast hast du
deutsch bestanden ich habe drei wir
machen direkt weiter mit mathe ich habe
hatte was sind 30 prozent von 1600
also ich dachte dass jetzt wenigstens
vernünftige rechenaufgaben kommen aber
ich glaube wenn man wirklich eine
hauptschulabschlussprüfung hat dann kann
man ja auch ein taschenrechner benutzen
also jetzt muss ich sie mir im kopf
machen also ich würde mich direkt mit
dem 30 rechnen sondern erstmal mit 10
das sind ja 160 und 160 x 3 sind 300 480
480 würde ich würde ich so sagen wichtig
ist 480 zwei orte auf einer landkarte
sind genau 15 zentimeter voneinander
entfernt die karte hat den maßstab 1 zu
100.000 wie weit sind die orte
tatsächlich voneinander entfernt
ich dachte gerade das ist echt schwierig
weil soll
eine aufgabe ist ich weiß nicht ob er
das auch habt aber bei mir war es immer
so wenn ich in der schule mathe aufgaben
hatte und die waren relativ lange dass
ich mich allein dadurch verwerten lassen
haben tun sein sollen deutsch war auch
nicht so meine stärke wenn paar sekunden
später
15.000
also 15 kilometer 100.000 zentimeter
entsprechend 1000 meter was wiederum
einem kilometer entsprechen
sie sind also 15 kilometer voneinander
entfernt die haben das ganze ein
bisschen einzige frage gerechnet als ich
aber ich war auch richtig also mathe
läuft gerade eigentlich was ist ein
viertel von 1 meter 20
sorry aber bei
den deutsch aufgaben soll man wissen
woher das wort qualifikationen den
ursprung hat und dann beim mathe geht es
darum ein meter 20 durch 430
also 3
also ein viertel mal 1,2 sind 0,3
nun kommen
30 cm wir deswegen möchte ich glaube ich
gerade 30 genau es sind 30 cm
kommen wir zur letzten matheaufgabe eine
wahl hat folgendes ergebnis kann die
dort hat 32 prozent der stimmen welches
dieser diagramme zeigt den wahlausgang
richtig ich dachte jetzt es wäre blöd
man müsste die prozent anhand von 23
millionen menschen die da gewählt haben
ausrechnen aber hier sondern einfach nur
sagen welches diagramm richtig ist also
dass hier auf keinen fall weil b ist
hier die hälfte und das sind ja hier 61
prozent dass hier das hier das hier weil
hierzu ja fast so groß wie a und sie hat
nur sieben prozent und 32 prozent das
rechte diagramm stellt den richtigen
ausgang da wenn du jetzt einen vierten
oder dritten punkt gemacht hast hast du
matte bestanden
okay ich habe deutsch bestand mit drei
von vier und mathe von mit vier von vier
wie gesagt stell mir gern weiter und in
die kommentare bei welchem punktestand
ihr gerade seid und wir kommen zum
letzten fach gesellschaftskunde also die
kombination aus geschichte erdkunde und
politik letztes mal bei dem grundschul
test sollte ich
[Musik]
lübeck ja ne ne zwei nachbarländer china
ich würde jetzt groß sagen japan und
russland hier sind sämtliche
nachbarländer aufgelistet
nein
das nicht dabei auf indien hätte ich
noch kommen können russland hatte ich ja
aber japan wo ist denn japan
bin ich komplett um
hier ist japan ja ok japan ist sehr
rechts ja es liegt nicht direkt daran an
aber es also kommen da ist das
ostchinesische meer dazwischen weiter
geht es mit politik
was ist eine koalition und was ist eine
opposition
eine koalition ist ein zusammenschluss
von zwei parteien und eine opposition
dachte ich früher zumindest immer wegen
von opportunity und blabla dass das
einfach eine partei ist die sage ich mal
ein größeres wie nennt man da einfach
die mehr stimmenanteile und mehr plätze
haben ich bin jetzt aber auch mal
gespannt wie die das hier erklären weil
das ist nichts was man in einem satz mal
kurz sagt oder wieder mathe aufgabe die
koalition ist ein bündnis von parteien
zur regierungsbildung wo sich dadurch
lassen sich beispielsweise zurzeit von
einer koalition regiert
die opposition besteht in einem
parlament aus denjenigen politischen
parteien die nicht die regierung bilden
okay das ist falsch wenn du das wusstest
dann notiere dir einen punkt ich wusste
eins von beiden wie heißt die hauptstadt
der usa washington washington dc
district of columbia heißt das glaube
ich es ist washington dc da kommen wir
auch schon das vorletzten verletzte in
welche besatzungszonen wurde deutschland
nach dem krieg aufgeteilt
herr
also ich weiß nicht ob es jetzt darum
geht wie das ganze unter frankreich und
blabla doch aufgeteilt wurde aber ich
würde sagen bundesrepublik deutschland
und ddr deutschland wurde in insgesamt
vier besatzungszonen aufgeteilt es gab
die sowjetische die amerikanische die
britische und die französische besatzung
ok
wenn du alle vier wusstest an notiere
dir wieder einen punkt und nun musste
auch wieder gucken ob du mindestens drei
der fragen richtig beantwortet habe ich
konnte das habe ich nicht
leute mathe hatte ich alles richtig
deutsch hat sich ein fehler und
gesellschaftskunde die drei fragen
falsch wenn ihr insgesamt alle drei
fächer also deutsch mathe und gse mit
jeweils drei oder vier punkten geschafft
hat dann habt ihr unseren test bestanden
das ist wahnsinn
den grundschul tester
und hier habe ich komplett
reingeschossen aber ist ja auch egal
meine lieben freunde ich würde das video
und der stelle jetzt auf jeden fall
beendet ich hab euch das video von
wissenswert morgen in der beschreibung
verlinkt unter dem video von denen in
der infobox in die auch noch den
kompletten qualifikations tests der
qualifizierenden hauptschulabschluss
arbeit des landes bayern wahnsinn oder
als das auch und wir merken konnte wenn
ein video hier gefallen hat das gerne
mal einen daumen hoch da soll ich das
ganze eventuell noch mit einem
realschule test machen
da werde ich dann wahrscheinlich gar
nichts wissen oder vielleicht sogar mit
einer abitur arbeit meine lieben freunde
schreibt mir gerne unten in die
kommentare schreibt mir mal wie viel er
davon wusste weil ich glaube ich bin
nicht der einzige der hier die komplett
verkackt hat alles läuft wieder dabei
[Musik]